[Musique]
qui présente les mots ça se passe salut
bienvenue dans cette vidéo on voit sa
venue dans cette vidéo on va doubler un
film connaissent et social vous
connaissez sociales desa souvent sur sa
chaîne regardez son antre est incroyable
connaissez sofiane je fais ça souvent
sur ma chaîne
on va expliquer quand même le concept
avant de lancer le film on met un film
alors l'occurrence et de film scarface
et on va doubler en totale improvisation
le film moi j'ai vu 6e 3 c'était un an
après les visiteurs
oui non mais c'est pas là j'étais qui
n'existait pas encore sur cette planète
mais que j'entendais jiwei trains cars
chicken je faisais attention à tout ce
que tu disais c'est parti attention on y
va on y va non d'accord prénom d'accord
je lui répondais non là c'est tellement
une négation super ok mon nom c'est
pascal pascal quai et ça c'est quoi un
petit coeur tu te fous de moi tu
t'appelles scarface et qu'il a patiné
scarface comme le type d'appel le nom du
film c'est comme si matrix appelé matrix
néo s'appelait matrix que le
velociraptor s'appelait jurassic park
que vous dit s'appeler toy story que je
la sens c'est un sens tout ça désolé que
jack sap et titanic lâchez moi les mecs
là chez moi c'est plus de coups que tous
les flics réunir hockey et je peux
continuer de parler de courrier parce
que parce que je m'y connais en couille
a atteint la coquette a les boules t
elle est grande
ouais les crottes de nez qui pense je la
connais je la fille née avant toi
qu'est-ce que la voirie de condé web s
il veut si je veux je suis policier mois
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour être fier car
il faut le brevet et ben je les vois et
regarde je te dire un truc je t'attrape
se rattrape dans la rue ce tonique
terrasse et si on se revoit dans la rue
ce tonique tahrir ce soit moi moi je te
vois je te défonce je te défonce
tellement on te manquer
salut loser j'ai le meilleur des
débardeurs hockey
ces manies machata salsa débardeur les
débardeurs ce qu'ils aient avec les
bailleurs débardeur je comprends pas
qu'il faut que tu lui dises a tenu à
pascal par la excuse moi ouais c'est
qu'ils pensent qu'il a un débardeur mais
c'est un [__] de tabliers qu'il faut
c'est pas ça je croit malin toi avec ton
ton cole ton ton cole a donc parlé il
dépasse de tous les côtés et toi avec
les cheveux en arrière comme si comme si
tu t'es tu dis ben là qu'il a tu sais
que j'ai un couteau
ouais ben moi j'ai des débardeurs j'en
ai 3 a pas de débats acharnés 3g j'en ai
marre d'avoir écouté les laisse le sait
un tablier cta mais tu es aveugle quoi
tu as l'air cool mec dit pacte un
débardeur si tu as un tablier
c'est la moindre des choses ok bats toi
tu te la faire mais je te casse la
bouche
ok tu portes un peu comme d'hab lié dit
le jeu tentant de dire digère tablier tu
veux partir j'ai un débardeur
ok c'est pas grave je pense que c'est un
débat mais tu m'as dit que c'est un
débardeur c'est vraiment la soirée je
passe pour un con devant
pourquoi hier mais je vais vous faire et
écoutez moi je vais me pendre à reculer
c'est ça ouais tu m'as devrait débarquer
de la gafta pire est maintenant ça sera
pas débardeur mois moi je bois d'oeuvre
et débardeur je sais pas ce qu'on doit
faire mais j'ai un plan vous m'écoutez
ok on y voit un second gram pic et pic
est collé fuck you à je t'emmerde
ça fait bien plaisir à voir bienvenue à
vous alors comme ça vous portez plus de
débardeurs vous avez lâché d'affaires ça
tombe bien parce qu'ici c'est les
chemises c'est le royaume de lâcher ça
me fait plaisir vous voir ça les manies
il a une cravate
je déteste les cravatés ce qui peut
l'enlever il peut l'enlever ou pas j'ai
demandé une fois ci je demande une
deuxième fois savant ne vénère il peut
enlever sa cravate c'est possible après
tu n'oses m comme on est où tu veux
qu'on soit tu crois que je faisais il
croit que je laime voulez mais
maintenant mais je demande
je dis ça j'ai dit ça comme ça c'est
accueilli chez moi j'ai pas dis que tu
es mais il faut peut-être pas s'emballer
mais non mais c'est une expression parce
que lui il a une cravate et [__] je te
propose un verre mais t'emballe pas ça
va pas dire que je t'aime tu veux boire
quoi paniquer pourquoi ils ont des
chaussures ici à l'intérieur
1 parce que c'est pourquoi ils sont des
[__] de chaussures parce que sinon tu
sers à rien pour rien je te paye pour
nettoyer un truc moi je suis hyper
propre message avait des gens juste pour
qu'ils dégueulasse chez moi dans ma
carrière je te jure [__] l'union face
à l'ire de trucs de l'accusé je te
souviens on s'était vus dans la masse
elle est munie d'un conte s'est vu dans
l'ascenseur je te rappelle je trouve la
porte c'est cool de rien non mais c'est
pas grave je dis jamais merci moi aussi
à nos points communs regarde up de rien
j'aime avec moi même je la fais 1 2 3
mais tu courbe quoi la fin bordel de
merde t'as l'air de compter un truc même
personne c'est ce que c'est on a l'air
con en attendant isoler les bergers pas
écouté le à chaque fois qu'il prend une
tomate il a match subit fois non c'est
bon de voir des fois
enfin ge pour la vallée direct
impossible j'ai fait tous les calculs ça
fait trois mois que je te regarde
j'analyse suis aux anges
tu m'as rallye mais ces malades les
fermes la [__] je provoque pas non
mais attends tu tu comptes même même un
choix mais arrête mais tu es fou donc là
tu compte mes cheveux tu va compter quoi
après tu va compter tous les débardeurs
que j'aime parce que j'en ai plage en ré
j'en ai j'ai beaucoup de débardeurs je
t'ai parlé de tous les débardeurs que
j'avais [__] pascal c'est quoi ton
problème
s'il aime conter les trucs qui compte
les trucs pourquoi cet usage assez
désarmés on est venu faire du business
avec le mec et toi tu tulle en tulle
embrouille comme ça on a tous nos toc
que j'ai pas confiance je veux dire est
ce que moi je te fais chier parce que tu
es affront sur les débardeurs
laisse nous tranquille jeudi contre des
trucs fait genre t'es comme lui contre
des trucs un citron ça va ça va tu as tu
as fait trois pas là voilà bien jouer
pascal on était en train de compter des
trucs pendant que vous étiez pas la
rapide un cake est ce que j'adore
compter des trucs aussi par exemple avec
tony et toi on est trois autour de la
pièce i à moi on est un ya toi on est 2
4-d voilà anthony 3 [__] conduit à au
moins fait les failles il sait pas
compter et a dit c'est ça le truc c'est
pas un toc c'est juste un peu trop
9679 2007 c'est impressionnant
oh [__] je lui mourir une fois je sens
au [__] à leur décès j'ai pas le temps
de compter mais je dirais comme toi
d'absents 464 4 167 6 doivent jeter
serait le plus précis mais était plus
fort que moi je ça s'apprend pas le
comté ça s'apprend dès la naissance mais
faux faux faux s'entraîner il faut se
réveiller le matin et se dire ah [__]
une journée sept jours dans la semaine
elle va vous comptez tout le temps quoi
et toi tu l'as un truc c'est là où je
t'admire toi et tu m'as pas répondu à la
question est alors quel âge as-tu pascal
34 allait vraiment rien c'est pas vrai
si c'est vous parce qu'on n'a pas la
même manière de conter jeu peu inspiré
je vais pas le vexer jeter 10 34 mais ça
peut être 33 s'appelle ça peut être 30 2
et c'est quoi ça peut te 8,8 à l'est pas
pour vite j'ai 8 ans m l'agent mais
regardez que lille salue bas alors
pascal qu'est ce que tu fous là c'est
marrant je te croyais à dijon je t'ai
manqué ou au pas du tout parce que là je
commence à me dire que ont fait la fête
sans moi quoi et ça ça me vexe un tout
petit peu donc je vais m'installer
ça vous dérange pas j'avoue que tu avais
l'air un peu vénère je comprenais pas
pourquoi c'est gentil de nous expliquer
mais c'est pas vraiment une fête s'est
improvisé hier - qui est passé au hasard
et puis il y avait déjà stéphane qui
étaient là et c'est pas vraiment une
soirée organisée sinon on aurait appelé
tu penses bien le prends pas comme ça
pascal bats tu sais bien qu'à chaque
fois qu'on fait une soirée fifa on
t'appelle d'accord pourquoi il ya un
événement facebook
si c'est pas organisé à tu prends un peu
au dépourvu là c'est pas moi et pour vue
là je t'ai pas demandé de bon je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire mais il ya quand
même un événement facebook tu arrive
pile à l'heure qu'est-ce que tu casses
les couilles terrien raté de la soirée
alors pour avoir évolué comme ça arrive
parce qu'on était mort de rire parce que
je faisais une blague au téléphone je me
suis auto feinte et j'ai fait j'en ai
raccroché elle a en fait eu raccrocher
pas j'ai un humour particulier mais tant
que ça blesse personne j'aime pas
l'humour communautaire
je fais juste des blagues téléphoniques
regarde par exemple là je vais faire
genre j'ai quelqu'un en ligne alors qu'à
personnes à l'eau ah oui je voudrais
commander une marguerite alors que ça
n'existe même pas comme pizza pourquoi
vous ne l'avez pas parce que ça n'existe
pas bon ce n'était pas la meilleure
blague mais moi ça me fait rire
ouais toi ça te fait pas rire je peux
comprendre tu me dis qui s'est rien
passé du tout et je vois que tu as fait
des blagues téléphoniques d'un humour
hyper pointu mais moi j'ai un humour de
merde si c'est que j'aime bien les
blagues téléphoniques away fait moins en
veine tout de suite j'ai plus d'idées de
black
j'avais deux idées j'ai fait les deux et
à c'était déjà pas ou s'il en fait une
troisième ça va être la honte à va
vraiment être claqué je le sens j'ai pas
beaucoup dans ce but
barraza d'abord l'événement facebook
maintenant plus d'idées de blague alors
qu'il existe au moins un au moins chez
plus haut - au moins neuf blige et je
pense je peux refaire une blague que
j'ai déjà fait
mais il y aura plus l'effet de surprise
l'effet de surprise ça marche toujours
par exemple les visiteurs un tout le
monde était surpris alors que les
visiteurs 2 tout le monde savait déjà
qui es tu vois que c'est des mecs du
moyen-âge dans le présent c'est beaucoup
moins surprenant du coup les gens au
moins aimé tu veux vraiment être déçu
pascal à l'eau c'est sarah sahara qui
s'accroche
ça va ça ça vous va parce que j'ai pas
c'est qui c'est sarah ça rappelle ce
qu'on n'ait pas de ça tu te fous de ma
gueule à un mec
toi tu te bats ne coiffe ses pattes au
[__] à l'eau vas-y vas-y continue à
londres et non un autre prénom jean
miranda et c'est miranda au téléphone
l apal téléphone miranda peut-être à
l'eau c'est qui c'est mieux miranda
ouais
vas-y continue
ces kids et moi qui sais tu me dis qu'il
ya quelqu'un au téléphone et je me dis
pas qui sait ça me saoule au [__] à
l'eau mais crois qu'on a inventé les
hauts parleurs en soixante dix ou quoi
[__] dix mois ce qui dit j'ai quelque
chose à vous dire très important pascal
vous n'avez pas huit ans j'ai appelé
votre maman il dit qu'il a appris votre
maman votre maman anne la palud m'a dit
quelque chose de très simple
tenez jouer j'entends j'entends en fait
ils haut-parleurs j'ai pas compris ce
qu'est ce vous m'entendez pascal oui
j'entends tétreault quoi le temps mais
[__] ça marche ou ça marche vous
calmer beccaro est la garantie d'une
once again castro vêtu 4g seraient pas
des pièces c'est ce que je vais faire
pascal je vais te racheter tout était
par des railleries j'ai plus envie je
vais te racheter pascal pascal je vais
te les racheter j'étais ravi gg j'ai
envie de le garder
tu sais quoi je vais je vais je vais je
vais les voir moi ah ouais tu vas aller
vendre toi je vais les voir de moi je
vais me faire un max de pognon
parce que le débardeur 6 c'est bien
c'est bien j'assume maintenant pascal se
braque
il est du débardeur a chuté ça ne coûte
rien du tout c'est des conneries moi je
vais en vente
je vais mettre des diamants dedans et
les gens vont les acheter c'est sûr ça
va revenir
débardeur très le prix d'un immeuble
[Rires]
cet immeuble vaudrait un débardeur bah
voilà oh je te parle pas de je te parle
qui tiennent qui tienne c'est ce qui
tient c'est léo les murs d où la maison
et ouais et les murs de toutes les
maisons du monde allait pascal je te
laisse je me barre je vois que tu as
envie de profiter simplement de ton
petit truc à toi tout seul
te baigner tout seul n'a pas voulu tu
m'aimes pas proposé de me baigner mec tu
as changé parce que tu es jaloux de mon
maillot de bain pascal tu es jaloux de
mon maillot de bain si tu le voyais là
tu serais jalouse
pourquoi je peux pas rentrer dans l'eau
pascal dis moi pourquoi tu me laisses
pas rentrer dis moi pourquoi est-ce que
je peux pas être l'intérêt devant ta
télé
pas raconter c'est tu rentres c'est un
poil en coulant à poil oui à poil tu
crois que je suis habillé mois à temps
mais je parvenir à poil alors j'ai un
super maillot de bain pascal [__]
qu'est ce qu'une plaie merde [__] tu
prends rien à la mode je me casse
ouais c'est ça et les murs y tienne ça
je les dis je le répéterai toute ma vie
que je sois seul ou pas bande d'enfoirés
c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous aura plu je vous
rappelle également qu on l'a fait une
vidéo doublage sur le film sin city sur
la chaîne youtube la mienne donc vous
pouvez y aller
abonnez-vous si cette vidéo vous a plu
on est sûr de la chaîne de golden
moustache
abonnez vous à cette chaîne si cette
vidéo vous a plu on est avec multiprise
abonnez vous à cette chaîne c'est cette
vidéo vous a plu à très vite on se
retrouve avec l'objectif sur la caméra
vas-y vas-y à loïc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]